what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading onto my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
oh man guys were finally here and we
really needed it like we really really
needed this because I think it only made
sense right I mean when you look at like
DC Comics you know you got Batman and
Superman they're like the one-two punch
of like the comic book world not just DC
but like the comic book world I mean
there's Batman as Superman and then
there's everybody else you know they go
in hierarchies after that but though
those stand the test of time is the two
most popular and over the years of their
publications we've see them as friends
we've seen them fight you know we've
seen uneasy alliances we've seen strong
friendships that have lasted generations
we've seen all different kinds of things
with their characters but we'd never
really seen an instance like this where
their sons became friends you know where
their sons would go on to carry on the
mantle or at least be the first steps
and carrying on the mantle of their
fathers now with regards to this story
what we initially do here is we pick up
with Jonathan Kent now keep in mind one
of the funny things about his character
this is one of the things I like about
him so much is despite the powers that
he will one day possess and despite the
power I guess the the godly level
abilities that he will one day inherit
at this moment right now he's still just
a kid and so he has all the same
thoughts as kids he'd used the world
like a kid does and that was the basis
behind him being raised the way he was
by Superman it would have been very easy
for Superman and Lois Lane to tell him
oh you're gonna be a god one day and
you're gonna be wildly powerful and for
him to allow that to go to his head and
view himself as somebody who's gonna be
you know this dictator grandiose kind of
person but instead they kept him down to
earth they were like you do not use your
superpowers your SuperSpeed to carry
groceries in the house you carry them in
just like everybody else
you're gonna do chores you're gonna do
all these things that kids do so they
would give him a strong work ethic they
would give him an strong understanding
of what it means to be a contributing
member of society one of the other ways
this shows itself is with some kid
that's giving him a hard time
now this kids not wildly important but
what is important is how Jonathan deals
with him but this kid being a bully he's
probably a bully because his life sucks
that's usually what happens with most
bullies their lives are really bad and
they just kind of express it outward by
being angry but Jonathan could have
easily just killed this kid
and he could just punched his head off I
mean he could have killed him in any one
of a thousand ways but instead he's just
like I'm not gonna worry about him I'm
gonna ignore him because that's what
you're that's what he was taught to you
that's what a normal human being does
you ignore those people who are bullies
you kind of blow him off let him you
know deal with their own misery and
whatever happens to him happens to him
you know you go
your life you continue on with your life
and you enjoy how great your life is and
that's what Jonathan was taught to do
but the other half of this is that once
he leaves the school he runs into a girl
named Maya Dakar now my de card is a
character that came out of the hole
rotten son of Superman / Batman and
Robin line up stories as part of the new
52 and those stories dealt with you know
the the expansion of Damian Wayne and
the new 52 line of stories that dealt
with the backstory of his character in
the new 52 they dealt with you know him
being raised by his mother as an
assassin in the year of blood when he
was killing people and his attempts to
make up for all that but during these
line of stories it was a guy named
Morgan decart and Morgan Ducard was he
was almost like Batman if Batman had
become hard like if he had followed the
teachings of the League of Assassins in
the sense that Morgan Dakar had no
problem torturing and killing people for
information this eventually led to him
coming into conflict with Batman and
Damian and Damian eventually killed
Morgan and because of this his daughter
Maya who was you know almost every ounce
and assassin as he was swore vendetta
against Damian Wayne but what happened
is in her attempts to track him down and
to kill him she basically became this
former villains now Ally where she
basically works alongside Damian Wayne
and in fact her being here is at the
request of Damian this is actually
what's kind of interesting is because as
the two of them get together you know as
the two of them spend time talking to
one another it's really just as kind of
glimpse of a thing it doesn't really
seem to be anything major
and eventually Jonathan and the young
girl that he's with leave and then she
takes off for her own thing because
she's terrified of being in this weird
like swamp place but the funny thing
about this is that because of the fact
that Jonathan is still very much a kid
he's scared of the same kind of things
kids are he really lets his imagination
run away with him and so we start seeing
things and he starts to loosen a ting
and some of this is the work of Maya
decart but the result is that Maya
basically takes him by surprise
and it seems like she ambushes him along
with Goliath now Goliath also came out
of those early stories with Damian and
during the time when he was tasked to be
an assassin he basically had to go and
capture this weird scepter thing but he
had to eliminate all these beasts that
were guarding this scepter and he chose
not to eliminate you know the smallest
of them and the reason why is because
the smallest of them touched his
humanity it basically made him cry for a
second and because of this he swore to
take it out of the zone and raise it as
his faithful companion more or less and
so Goliath has basically been there ever
since it's really kind of like a mask
out
Damian Wayne and there are fans out
there who love Goliath who are like
Elias is amazing because despite not
being human and being able to talk
Goliath has a lot of personality in
terms of how it relates to things like
the c-3po is the Damian Wayne line of
stories but the fact remains here that
you know my dick hard at least seems to
initially take out Jonathan Kent
alongside Goliath and then when Jonathan
wakes up he's being held captive by
Damian Wayne and this is where things
get hilarious you know because Damian's
like dude you're a danger man like
you're a dangerous person
you have powers that you don't really
know about them yet you know but you're
going to to manifest those eventually
you don't know how to control them you
killed your cat I mean it's the it's
hilarious because you know Damian in and
of himself is extremely capable Damian's
very very capable in terms of his
abilities but he's still just a kid -
and that's the cool thing about this is
you know this story puts that into
perspective it reminds us that even
though Damian Wayne's one of the best
assassins in the world you know even
though Jonathan is the son of Superman
in a lot of ways like their kids they're
they're you know young kids they're
young boys and they see the world and a
young way and so what happens is with
Damian Wayne interrogating Jonathan Kent
Batman shows up and he's like what the
hell have you done and Damian's like WOM
just I'm interrogating him because he's
dangerous and he's like dude you have no
idea what you've just done
and then suddenly Superman comes barging
in now this is the kicker because
Superman's
yes someone kidnapped his son of course
he was able to find him but his initial
reaction is Batman had a son kidnapped
and so he's not Superman angry at Batman
you know because you've used was a bad
guy he said he's a concerned father he's
an angry father whose son went missing
it's like taking Cubs from mama there
you know you just it only someone with a
death wish would do something like that
and so of course as soon as Superman
gets here Batman tries to talk him down
he's like hey man look this is not what
you think it is and he's able to do that
but only because of the fact that
Jonathan creates a barrier between the
two of them he's like look you guys need
to chill you guys need to relax and he
gives them some much-needed time to stop
you know panicking and it gives them so
much the time to talk but also because
of her stealth ability is the initial
idea of
is that no one's gonna know she's there
but Superman picks up on her immediately
I mean just because of his hearing and
is seen and so on and so forth and so
Maya basically has to reveal herself you
know to everybody but in any event the
idea here is that Batman
you know while Jonathan is here they
begin to sort of examine Jonathan and
the reason why is because as we've seen
in the Superman line of comics and even
in the more recent issues of Action
Comics Superboy or Jonathan Kent's
powers are manifesting but they're
intermittent and so he will have
durability but then he won't
you know he'll have heat vision and then
he won't and the question is why is it
because he's just a growing boy or is it
because there's something going on with
him now on the surface this seems
totally unimportant it seems totally
unattentive but it's extremely important
because what this does is it shows us
that Superman's just like any father
ever you know every single parent ever
if their kid comes down with a coffee oh
my god why is my kid coughing you know
is it because I have a cold or because
there's something seriously wrong
parents have an instinct to ensure their
children stay protected even after their
children grow into adults it's just a
parental instinct it's just a thing that
people do and so for Superman you know
maybe he's overreacting maybe he's not
but the way he's acting is very much
like any father and so it's basically
Tomasi telling us yeah Superman's got
these godly abilities yeah he didn't
move planets and he's fought Darkseid
and he fought doomsday all that kind of
stuff when it comes down to it he's also
a dad he's also just a dad worried about
his son and so from here we transition
to Damian Wayne and and Jonathan and
Damian's basically giving Jonathan you
know a tour around the Batcave the
things that are there if we get to see
back ow bat cow yeah bad cow is amazing
I don't know how many of you guys know
about bad cow but it ran out in front of
a car bat cow bat cow is awesome but but
again you know Tomasi just kind of gives
us this rivalry between the two and he
actually has you know Jonathan punch
Damian but it's just kind of this
rivalry between the two more listening
I'm not really saying they hate each
other
so much as they view each other as
rivals and this is really kind of cool
because Damian wouldn't consider
Jonathan Kent a rival if Jonathan Kent
wasn't somebody worth worrying about now
a lot of what Jonathan Kent's doing here
is just reactionary to the goading to
the prodding that Damian Wayne is
putting towards him but because Damian
knows how skilled he is in terms of his
abilities because he's trained under the
League of Assassins
and because he's trained under Batman he
knows what he's capable of
but the fact that he looks at Jonathan
and sees him as a rival tells us just
how capable Jonathan is as well even if
he doesn't know it and so because of the
fact of the two of them are fighting
amongst each other this is very
indicative of how things were between
you know Batman and Superman when they
first met now every time they meet with
a reboot or anything like that they
always fight one another wouldn't they
always realize you're both going for the
same goal and they end up becoming
partners sometimes it takes a little
while for them to transition to being
friends sometimes it happens right off
the bat but the fact remains that
there's usually always a conflict
between the two of them but instead of
something allowing you know allowing
these two to work things out with due
time instead what happens is they
basically say look we're going to put
them through a boot camp we're going to
force them to work together and either
at the end of all this they're going to
come out as teammates or they're going
to come out as enemies and there's
nothing we can do and so what we do is
we pick up out in the wilderness out in
the middle of nowhere where they
basically just been dropped off by by
Batman and Superman and they're kind of
left to their own devices Damian Wayne
doesn't have his various gadgets with
him and Jonathan's powers aren't in full
activation so he doesn't really know how
to use them completely plus he doesn't
have the ability to fly yet and so there
are a lot of drawbacks to him so in a
lot of ways he's just almost as
powerless as Damian Wayne but the other
half of this is not as though Batman and
Superman abandon them not at all you
know you got Superman in the sky
watching everything happen as they're
making their way to where these three
challenges are supposed to undergo but
you've also got Batman who's watching
these events unfold as well and so neo
they haven't left I mean something
they're gonna let them die nothing like
that you know we're simply just trying
to get the two of them to work together
and initially it's really this thing of
each time they pass a challenge they
basically received something they
received part of their uniforms or they
received some gadgets and it's basically
just saying you guys need to work
together to get past these challenges
and by getting past these challenges
together you're going to form a bond do
at the very least you're gonna form a
mutual respect for one another so that
even if you don't become the best of
friends you're gonna have a respect for
what the others capable of now the other
half of this is that while they're
working together while they're trying to
get through this of course Maya shows up
periodically but they also have to fight
against Goliath and you know again this
is really one of those things where
because it's not you know a super deadly
situation initially Damian calls Goliath
off but a Goliath you know doesn't
respond right off the
eventually he does but he doesn't
respond well off the bat but more so
than that you know with these different
traps and and scenarios that have been
set up there are a couple close calls
there are a couple instances where it's
possible that they will die and in fact
there is an instance where Alfred says
hey look we need to step in you know and
Batman says no you know Superman
you know like Alfred tells Superman you
got to get in there you got to save him
and Batman says no now this is very
important because it highlights the very
different methods by which Batman and
Superman were laid to their sons because
Batman you know lives within Gotham City
and exists to protect Gotham City in and
of itself
Damian Wayne's experience as part of the
League of Assassins meant that once he
showed up at that man's side he was
already ahead of the curve you know he
already knew how to fight he already
knew how to how to engage a multitude of
enemies and how to take them out
he was already capable in terms of his
abilities so Batman didn't really have
to do a whole lot the only thing he had
to do was really curb Damian Wayne's
bloodlust and teach him that it's not
okay to kill everybody that you come
across it's not okay to kill every
villain that you fight with Jonathan
however he basically lived in the
suburbs you know and so he was never
exposed to constant conflict he was
never tested in the fires of death and
destruction and so he's basically coming
out of this as a chalkboard you know as
a completely clean board and so he's
basically learning how to fight as he
fights he's learning how to survive as
he survives now it doesn't mean that
he's incapable of doing these things it
simply means that for him he's basically
learning what it means to be a hero
outside of the bits and pieces of wisdom
that he gets from his father now
eventually this sort of mutual respect
begins to blossom into a friendship when
the two of them are with Goliath and
they basically spend the night
camped out you know in order to figure
out what they're gonna do when the
morning comes around but there's a
really funny scene here and this this is
actually really touching I really like
this there's a really cool scene where
Jonathan offers Damian a granola bar now
Damian does the right thing and he turns
it down but in the end he ends up taking
it anyway which I'm not sure why he did
I can't think of very many man that
would willingly eat granola bars Benny
I'm talking about you so um the two of
them also come to the realization on
what it is that Batman and Superman are
looking for right I mean they're they're
not in this with no idea of what's going
on they know that Batman as Superman
wants them to work together and in truth
it's really just stubbornness
it's the stubbornness of boys to kind of
sidetrack here for a second
guys and a lot of boys have a very high
level of pride Dameon especially in the
story Jonathan not so much but Damien
definitely has a lot of pride I always
liken Damien to Vegeta from Dragon Ball
Z in the sense that Damien does not like
admitting what he can't do something he
doesn't like appearing weak because he
was taught you know he was taught that
weakness or to show weakness is a
failure and it'll lead to death
neo Batman has curbed that and said hey
look it's always okay to ask for help if
you need help but Damien still has a
very hard time dealing with that it's
one of the reasons why Damien does have
a lot of people that hate him
I love his character because watching
him evolve from where he used to be to
where he is now
is one hell of a journey to witness it's
an incredible experience when you go
through and you read Batman and Robin
and you read you know Robin said a
Batman other there just some some
extremely well told stories if you can
read between the lines but ultimately
because the two of them come to this
realization on with what Batman and
Superman are looking for but they kind
of come to this unwritten exception that
yeah they need to work together they
come to this unwritten agreement that
yes they they basically have to help one
another the issue with this is that once
the night passes and we get back into
the day it almost seems like the the
exact same situation they just don't
really work together like they should
and the result is that an artificial
hurricane ends up leading to the two of
them being caught unawares and
presumably being defeated or more or
less failing the challenge and so
Superman basically shows up and says hey
look like you guys you guys failed and
this endeavor you know you guys were
we're supposed to be taught to work as a
team you know the the costumes that you
wear are not just costumes to look good
the counselors that you wear aren't just
cool because we all know that having a
cape is amazing like the costumes that
you wears and stand for something
important it stands for teamwork it
stands for sacrifice it stands for
putting other people above yourself it
stands for the fact that those people
who stand beside you and conflict are
people that have to be able to trust you
and if they can't trust you then you
might as well not be there
it stands for some very very important
things and this is a lesson they simply
haven't learned and so you know Superman
tells them you guys just something I'm
ready for this you guys are not ready
for this particular this particular
challenge and so making their way back
to to the Batcave once they arrive you
know with Superman having taken off
before them once they get there they
find that Batman and Superman are under
attack now of course you know this is
designed to basically teach them this
final lesson you know this is on to
teach them that there
the lives of people around them depend
on them working together that's really
the basis behind this meal is to teach
them that when other people's lives are
on the line it's not the time to bicker
and it's not the time to argue is the
time to put yourself in the background
and put the lives of other people first
and that's exactly what Damian and
Jonathan do and it's spectacular to see
you know Damian Wayne is is so
intelligent when it comes to conflict
when it comes to strategic aspects when
it comes to being capped achill but
Jonathan also has some some strong
abilities things that Damian just can't
do and so using Damian's intelligence
alongside Jonathan's abilities
complement each other perfectly and so
they're able to overcome this force and
they're able to free their fathers and
so in doing so Superman and Batman
basically sit down and they say that's
what you guys are now you guys are not
just random dudes anymore you know
you're not just a couple kids running
around with costumes wanting to play
superheroes
you guys are superheroes now you guys
are protectors of the planet Earth in
the best way you know how that you guys
are effectively super sons so with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end again this is just a little
two-part story but damn I thought it was
good I thought it was so fun
um I can't wait to see what we what we
get from these two guys and I'll be
honest with you you know once their
power you know once once the powers of
Jonathan allow him to actually step into
the official Superboy mancell in terms
of what he's capable of and fight some
reasonable foes right alongside his dad
I'd love to see these two on the Justice
League to be honest I'd love to see
Barry Allen and Batman and Superman you
know and you know the Green Lantern's
and Damian Wayne and Jonathan Kent I'd
love to see them there with the very
least we get something that's that's the
return of like Young Justice or
something along those lines you know
that kind of throws them in there I mean
I guess we have Teen Titans I guess you
could put Jonathan Kent on Teen Titans
oh yeah you could put Jonathan Kent on
Teen Titan man I did I would supposed to
comment down below let me know what you
guys think I'd love to see Jonathan Kent
on the on the Teen Titans but if you
guys are new here to college explain be
sure to hit the sub button and become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video drop a like and I will catch
you all in it peace